-Today is Friday and that's
usually when I catch up
with some personal stuff,
you know, I
check my inbox and return
some emails and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I was running behind today,
so I thought,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out
my weekly thank-you notes
right now.
Is that cool with you guys?
[ Cheering and applause ]
I appreciate it.
James, can I get
some thank-you note writing
music, please?
[ Playing tender tune ]
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, boy.
-Good, isn't it?
♪♪
Thank you,
this year's Oscars set,
for looking like you were filmed
in IKEA's outdoor
furniture section.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
That's real.
-IKEA, yes.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you,
Oscar-nominated movies
that were only released
on streaming,
or, as straight-to-DVD
movies put it,
"Oh, so, now,
this is a celebrated thing?"
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
"Okay.
Okay."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-"So, now, it's
a celebrated thing? Okay."
[ Laughter ]
-Rules got changed.
-"Okay. We're doing that,
now, I guess. Okay."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, AirTag,
for being the name
of Apple's new device tracker,
as well as a great game idea
for an only child.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Billy, go outside
and play AirTag.
"You're it, air!
[ Laughter ]
Okay, we're doing that, now?
Okay, okay.
-Just not liking it.
-Oh, we're doing that, now?
Okay."
[ Laughter ]
-God.
-You're overreacting.
-"No, no."
-"Oh, we're doing that, now,
I guess. Okay."
♪♪
Thank you, Stouffer's
new lasagna mac,
for being the tastiest way
to let people know
you're going through
some stuff right now.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Just get off my back.
Looks pretty good to me, man.
Do you think you
can taste the difference
between the cheese and sauce,
than the mac,
the cheddar cheese?
-You mean the mac cheese?
It's lasagna mac, so it's made
with macaroni & cheese,
but lasagna-style.
-It's lasagna, but,
in the middle of the lasagna is
macaroni & cheese.
-Yeah, I think I could tell.
[ Laughter ]
I have a food problem,
so I'm sure I could tell.
-You have what?
-A food problem.
I love food.
[ Laughter ]
-A food problem?
-Yeah.
Problem with food.
-What's the problem?
I said I'm on a seafood diet.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Yeah.
-You "see food,"
you eat it, right?
-No, no, no. Fish, shellfish.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-You know, clams. Trying to keep
the cholesterol down.
-Sorry.
I misunderstood.
I thought you were making a --
-Oh, you thought I said
"s-e-e" diet.
-[ English accent ] Well,
I thought you were,
perhaps, doing
-A comical bit?
-some humor.
-No. I was merely telling you
a fact about my, uh,
dietary means.
-No, understood.
I thought you said
you're on a "see food" diet
-I did.
-and you going
to finish it up with,
"I see food, I eat it."
But, instead,
you're on a seafood diet.
Of course, you're talking
about shrimp and trout,
maybe sea bass, maybe.
-Yes.
-Maybe a thick sea bass.
-Thick, thick chunk of sea bass.
-Yes.
-With some chili mac over it.
-Yes. Or some of the whole fish
under salt.
[ Italian accent ]
Branzino!
[ Laughter ]
For two!
-[ Italian accent ]
Due branzini!
-Due branzini!
[ Laughter ]
-[ English accent ]
Can you smother that
with some Stouffer's
lasagna mac?
[ Laughter ]
-[ English accent ]
Can you take this fish
and just completely ruin it
by putting microwave
pasta on top, but then --
[ Laughter ]
I think it's a mistake.
I think the lasagna's one thing
and I'm down for Stouffer's.
I'm a French bread pizza dude.
I love those.
-Sure.
Yeah, I'm all for that.
-Lasagna? Sure. Get it.
Mac & cheese? Sure.
-Together? Good.
-No, I think it's a mistake.
It's the same.
It's going to destroy
the flavors. It's -- No.
-You think it might even
take down lasagna.
-Yeah, I think I might
take it out. Take it down.
-They wouldn't do that
in Naples, in Napoli.
-Oh, they'd get so mad.
-Yeah. They'd be like --
[ Italian accent ]
Branzini!
-[ Italian accent ]
What are you doing?!
[ Falsetto faux Italian ]
[ Baritone
faux Italian ]
[ Falsetto faux Italian ]
[ Baritone
faux Italian ]
[ Creaky faux Italian ]
[ Baritone
faux Italian ]
-Stouffer's.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
That's a weird ad.
-Yeah. Odd ad.
That was a commercial
for Stouffer's?
-Yeah, it was
a commercial for Stouffer's.
-People in Italy arguing?
-Yeah, they're arguing
about how...
-They woke the grandma.
-Yeah, they woke Grandma up
out of bed.
[ Laughter ]
Are we on "Popular Mathematics"?
-What's that?
Yeah. No, no,
we're doing a different bit --
thank-you notes.
-Oh, sorry.
I zoned out for a sec.
No problem, bud.
[ Chuckle ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, giant explosions,
for meaning one
of three things --
a fire, a gas leak,
or a gender reveal gone wrong.
[ Cheering and applause ]
No, that's too real.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, Natty Light's
new frozen icicles,
for not going
by your original name --
Go-gurt for Drunks.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Natty Light!
-Natty Light, yeah.
That makes anyone --
If you call Natural Light
Natty Light,
it's your first Light.
-That should say something
about you.
-How many Stouffer's macs
do you got? Oh.
-"They're even better
non-frozen."
[ Laughter ]
-You were eating them frozen?
-They're just beer?
"Yeah, beer in a tube.
They should put it in a can."
[ Laughter ]
-"Then, you can drink it
all day long."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you,
white noise machines,
for getting me to pay $80,
when it could've just put
a bucket over a fan.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Was that your
white noise machine?
-Yeah.
[ Whirring ]
Pbbbt!
[ Laughter ]
Pbbt!
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Pbbt!
♪♪
-Come on, dude.
-Krrrh!
-Come on, man.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
♪♪
Thank you, baggage claim,
for being an amusement park
for my luggage.
[ Awws and applause ]
Have some fun.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, Necco Wafers,
or, as I like to call you,
dessert Tums.
There you have it, everybody.
[ Applause ]
Those are our thank-you notes.